vous avez tous devoir enfiler plus
rapidement possible votre salopette
bleue votre casquette rouge et votre
moustache les 5 plus rapide vont à
l'épreuve d'après c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
la salopette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merde deuxième épreuve vous êtes
maintenant 5 il va falloir lancer les
pots de Madame dans le tuyau les deux
premiers j'ai quoi excusez-moi c'est
quoi le jeu là c'est dans le saut c'est
dans le saut c'est quoi le jeu alors
donc on va devoir lancer les peaux de
bananes dans le seau si il m'a compris
les mecs excusez-moi tu peux m'expliquer
le jeu là parce que
là pour ça il pourrait non mais tu peux
m'expliquer le jeu s'il te plaît non
mais sérieux oui mais pourquoi il y a
pas de marque pourquoi il y a pas de
marque tu te fous de ma gueule c'est
comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans le même tour et non pas de même
tour pour ceux qui font le ramadan
merci attention c'est parti tu mords
attention
[Applaudissements]
la finale oppose donc Delphine Wespiser
et Gilbert
attention on va faire la finale un Mario
Kart avec les téléphones vous connaissez
la règle du jeu on joue à deux points
gagnants si le téléphone tombe c'est
perdu c'est bien sûr le plus près du
bord qui gagne la manche je voudrais
est-ce qu'on peut avoir des téléphones
s'il vous plaît il est où mais il est
parti lui non mais excuse-moi tu fais
toujours partie de l'émission
non mais dis-le-moi sinon alors
mettez-vous là-bas
mettez-vous là-bas mettez-vous là-bas
attention ça c'est pour marquer les
téléphones
franchement c'est quoi ça c'est normal
ça
aussi n'importe quoi ouais franchement
c'est normal ça non mais si on décoller
non mais oh tu sais Luna là
[Rires]
ça veut dire quoi ça c'est quoi ça c'est
un choix de doigts de partir sur W9
aussi
[Rires]
je te le dis ça
va être le plus près du bord si le
téléphone tombe c'est éliminé c'est en
deux points gagnants le grand gagnant je
vous dis la vérité Gilles Verdez jouera
pour cette partie du public gagnera un
cadeau
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
vous savez pas ce que c'est que le
cadeau
Delphine
c'est toi qui va choisir est-ce que tu
choisis de commencer ou de laisser
Gilles commence
j'ai choisi de laisser Gilles commencer
merci
pense à toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien parti
[Rires]
de légende de la télévision attention
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de vous proposer un deal avec
le public toute cette partie là a perdu
mais je demande à cette partie
on peut faire un jeu un dernier deal
est-ce que vous êtes comme on dit
altruiste
al qui vient du latin Al Pacino
truie qui vient de la truite
ce que vous êtes en voilà avenant avec
les truies
[Rires]
c'est moi
on peut refaire une série entre moi et
Gilles
si c'est une qui gagne tout le monde
perds
si je gagne
je fais gagner tout le public
mais chaque partie là peut dire non les
gars nous on a notre cadeau quoi qui
arrive on s'en fout de vous c'est quoi
le cadeau c'est quoi le cadeau le cadeau
il arrive dans un instant
[Rires]
c'est
une journée dans un parc aquatique
[Applaudissements]
et il y en a trois qui ont rien capté
[Rires]
un parc aquatique à Punta Cana c'est
attention
honneur aux dames tu démarres
en deux points en deux points
par contre j'ai un super cadeau pour toi
et Fatou
non non non
et pense à toi
dans un parc aquatique
à quoi
j'ai une vision de rêve si Gilbert
personne ne gagne vont rentrer hein vous
allez dans votre baignoire vous faites
pas chier
pas les noisettes et puis c'est bon si
je gagne tout le monde part au parc
aquatique
[Applaudissements]
celui qui tombe est éliminé c'est lui
qui est éliminé bien sûr sur Ajouter au
lion
c'est très simple
et Dieu sait que l'élégance merci fait
partie de ta personne bravo à toi on est
aussi élégant tu veux que je te dise je
vais te dire toi tu sens le cul
au sens premier du terme
allez c'est parti mon chéri on y va
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
c'est nul non
c'est quoi la partie basse ou la partie
haute c'est la partie haute
tout simplement la spécialiste c'est
Valérie là tu fais quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dois je dois le rattraper en cas de
chute
[Rires]
oh là là
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout il a craché dessus
il est à toi viens ici
[Rires]
rien compris toi téléphone de merde
est-ce que vous faites pas tous les deux
en entraînement déjà qu'on ferait pas
d'entraînement tous les deux vous la
mettez comme ça
[Rires]
non non non
je vous dis la vérité moi je pense qu'il
faut je trouve que là c'est honteux
vas-y allez vas-y colle à la tête
j'ai pas le droit de choisir mon côté
[Rires]
que j'en ai déjà vu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dieu du smartphone
donne-moi la force
Eric sonne moto
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ah ouais
pourquoi tu as mis
non mais il est attiste
[Rires]
est-ce que est-ce que Gilles il aura pas
moins 1
fais gaffe
à votre disposition
ouais c'est moins bon là alors
[Applaudissements]
il y a un partout là
[Rires]
Jardiland
[Applaudissements]
la personne que je suis
[Musique]
[Rires]
parc aquatique qui va le payer
c'est pas W9 qui vont faire un chien
[Rires]
je pourrais très bien me dire non je
vais faire exprès de perdre ça je garde
l'oseille pour moi j'envoie mes enfants
Punta Cana terminée
la messe est dite mais Hanouna c'est pas
comme ça
je vais me battre jusqu'au bout malgré
ma blessure à la cheville
dans les appuis
[Rires]
c'est un demi
[Musique]
alors les gars je suis désolé j'ai perdu
tout le public a perdu
c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça j'ai perdu j'ai perdu
j'ai perdu le public a perdu